[موسيقى]
في خطوه تصعيديه لافته مليئه بالرسائل
والدلالات اقدمت حكومه نتنياهو التي توصف
بالاكثر تطرفا في تاريخ الحكومات
الاسرائيليه على عقد جلسه لها داخل نفق
اسفل الناحيه الغربيه من المسجد الاقصى
وذلك احيانا للذكرى السادسه والخمسين
لاحتلال القدس
فقط هذه الخطوه مع اقتحام وزير الامن
الاسرائيلي اتمار باحات المسجد الاقصى
للمره الثانيه منذ توليه المنصه مثل هذه
الخطوات الاستفزازيه الخطيره وما يرافقها
من زياده مضطرده في اجراءات تهويد القدس
خاصه بالاستمرار في حفر الانفاق اسفل
المسجد الاقصى وتوسعها قبلت بتنديد
فلسطيني وعربي واسلامي ومعارضه دوليه
متفاوته فما الذي تضمره حقيقه هذه الحكومه
للقدس واهلها وما هي مالات كل هذه
الاستفزازات التي لم توقفها بيانات السجب
والادانه اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من
سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم منذ ان قامت اسرائيل باحتلال
مدينه القدس عام 67 من القرن الماضي وهي
تعمل جاهده للسيطره عليها وتغيير معالمها
بهدف تهويدها من خلال العديد من
الانتهاكات والتعديات في محاوله لايجاد
روايه تؤيد وجود تاريخ لليهود في المدينه
المقدسه وانهاء الوجود العربي فيها حول
مالتي هذه السياسه
وسبل التصدي لها يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في
هذه الحلقه من القدس ناصر الهدمي رئيس
الهيئه المقدسيه لمناهضه التهويد من القدس
ايضا اسامه السعدي المحامي والنائب العربي
السابق في الكنيسه الاسرائيلي ومن انقره
الدكتور محمد الحلايقه نائب رئيس الوزراء
الاردني السابق فاهلا بهم جميعا
حكومه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وخلال اجتماعا
مثيرا للجدل عقدته في نفق تحت المسجد
الاقصى صدقت على مجموعه من القرارات
الراميه لتهويد مدينه القدس تضمنت خطه
لبناء الاف الوحدات الاستيطانيه الجديده
ومشروعات تعزز الانفاق اسفل الحرم القدسي
[موسيقى]
هذه لحظه يراد لها اسرائيليا ان تكون
منعطفا في تاريخ القدس والمسجد الاقصى انه
اجتماع لحكومه نتنياهو في نفق اسفل الحرم
القدسي خصص للتصديق على مشاريع تهويد
جديده في مدينه القدس المحتله ليس الحدث
سابقه في التاريخ فمثل ذلك فعلت حكومه
نتنياهو نفسه عام 2017
لكن المختلف هذه المره هو طابع حكومته
التي يسيطر عليها اليمين المتطرف الذي
يبدو حريصا على استغلال المرحله لتحقيق
طموحاته في السيطره على المقدسات للحدث
فيما زامنه من وقائع دلالات تستدعي التوقف
عندها
[تصفيق]
فاجتماع النفق جاء بوعيده مسيره الاعلام
التي ينظمها المتطرفون اليهود سنويا منذ
احتلال القدس الشرقيه
وسبق ذلك بساعات اقتحام جديد للمسجد
الاقصى من طرف وزير الامن القومي اتمرن
غفير ما يوحي بتسريع التوجه نحو تحقيق
التقسيم المكاني للحرم القدسي
وجاء الاجتماع ايضا بعد اسبوع من نهايه
العدوان على قطاع غزه الذي استهدف قاده من
الصف الاول في حركه الجهاد الاسلامي تريد
حكومه نتنياهو ان تكسب تاييد الشارع
الاسرائيلي الذي ما يزال منذ اسابيع
منقسمه اذ لم تتوقف ثوره الرافدين لمشروع
تعديلات النظام القضائي فهل ينجحون تنياهو
في صرف الانظار عن ذلك الى مشاريع تهويد
القدس وهل يكفي ذلك لانقاذه من ورطته
الداخليه
ما يطغى على المشهد حتى الان يوجه الاضواء
الى مشاريع الحكومه التي صدقت عليها خلال
ذلك الاجتماع المثير للجدل وتضمنت مخططا
تكلفته 95 مليون شيكل لبناء الاف الوحدات
الاستيطانيه في القدس وتشجيع المستوطنين
على السكن فيها وفي الضفه الغربيه كما
صدقت الحكومه على اضافه ما يعادل نحو 17
مليون دولار لميزانيه حفر الانفاق تحت
حائط البراق والبلده القديمه
ينظر للتوجهات نتنياهو وحكومته على انها
مساء لتسريع احداث تغيير في الوضع القائم
في القدس فالمشاريع الاستيطانيه الجديده
تستهدف توسيع حدود القدس وتعزيز الحزام
الاستيطاني حولها تعول اسرائيل على ذلك
لتحقيق مكاسب عده من قبيل مضاعفه اعداد
المستوطنين في القدس وتطويق التجمعات
السكنيه الفلسطينيه وعزل القدس وضواحيها
عن مح يطها الفلسطيني من نواحي الشمال
والجنوب والشرق فهل ستمضي خطط نتنياهو
وحكومته قدما بينما يتراكم لدى
الفلسطينيين مزيد من اسباب المقاومه
هذا ويواجه المسجد الاقصى منذ احتلال
القدس مشروعا تهويديا دينيا بكافه الوسائل
فيما يلي ابرز الاعتداءات ومحاولات
التهويده في المدينه والمسجد الاقصى
في السابع من حزيران يونيو عام
1967 رفع عالم الاحتلال على مسجد القبه
الصخره وسلبت مفاتيح ابواب الاقصى وفي
الحادي والعشرين من اب اغسطس عام
1969 اقدم متطرف من اصل استرالي على اشعال
النيران بالمصلى القبلي بالمسجد الاقصى
وفي الثامن من تشرين اول اكتوبر عام 1990
حاول متطرفون يهود وضع حجر الاساس لما
يسمونه بالهيكل الثالث فتصدى لهم مرابطون
في المسجد الاقصى فاطلق جنود الاحتلال
النار على المصلين ما ادى الى استشهاد
واحد وعشرين شخصا
وفي عام 2003 اغلقت سلطات الاحتلال مصلى
باب الرحمه لغايه منتصف شباط فبراير 2019
في عام 2003 بدات اقتحامات المتطرفين
اليهود للمسجد الاقصى بقرار قضائي وفي عام
2006 بدات الاقتحامات الجماعيه وصولا الى
تاديه صلوات تنموذيه علنيه في ساحات
المسجد ومن المؤشرات الاحصائيه عن تهويد
القدس ان عدد السكان اليهود في المدينه
بشطريها بلغ 500 وتسعين الف شخص اي حوالي
61% من السكان في حين بلغ عدد السكان
الفلسطينيين
375 الف نسمه اي حوالي 39% من السكان
وخلال العام 2022 صدقت سلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على بناء نحو 70 مخططا
استيطانيا لبناء اكثر من عشره الاف وحده
في محافظه القدس ومحيطها في الوقت الذي
هدمت فيه سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اكثر
من 258 مبنى في القدس واصدرت قرارات لهدم
اكثر من 220 مبنى
وتحاصر اسرائيل القدس بنحو 15 مستوطنه
تسمى مستوطنات الطوق كما يتغلغل الاستيقان
في قلب الاحياء العربيه في الشطر الشرقي
المحتل وفي البلده القديمه وحدها هناك نحو
70 بؤره استيطانيه كما ان الجدار العازل
يحرم اكثر من خمسين الفا من حمله الهويه
المقدسيه من الاقامه بمدينه القدس
نرحب بضيوفنا من جديد ونبدا من القدس
والسيد ناصر الهدمي
ما الذي تريد اسرائيل
بعد كل هذا الذي فعلته وتفعله ما الذي
تريده من القدس تحديدا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك ولضيوفك
الكرام ولجمهور المشاهدين اهلا وسهلا
الاحتلال مضى على قيامه على ارض فلسطين 75
عاما 75 عاما ولا زال هناك من ينازع
الاحتلال السياده على ما تسميه دوله
الاحتلال العاصمه 75 عاما ولم يستطع
الاحتلال ان ينهي الصراع القائم بين الشعب
الفلسطيني الثابت على ارضه وبين دوله
الاحتلال التي بدات حتى تنحسر
وتتراجع شيئا فشيئا كل هذا يعبر تماما انه
بالنسبه لافكار الاحتلال ان الاوان ان يتم
حسم المعركه انا الاوان ان تحس دوله
الاحتلال انها دوله ذات سياده وذات سيطره
على كافه اجزائها ولكن هذا ليس موجودا
لذلك نعم جاءت هذه الحكومه التي كما ذكرت
حضرتك اكثر تطرفا اكثر يمي اكثر فاشيه
اكثر اجراما بحق الشعب الفلسطيني جاءت
لتحسم القضيه لتنهي هذا الصراع طبعا وفق
معطيات كانت تظن انها قادره على هذا الامر
وانها ستستطيع ان تنهي هذا الصراع
باجراءات تجريها على ارض الواقع وينتهي
الامر فكان من اهم المراكز التي ينظر الى
الاحتلال على انها مركز السياده هي المسجد
الاقصى المبارك ويعني يحضرني تصريح لرئيس
الكنيست امير روحانه الذي قال من في
الاجتماع الاخير الذي جرى اسفل البلده
القديمه بالقرب من المسجد الاقصى المبارك
في احد الانفاق قال ان من يسيطر على جبل
الهيكل يسيطر على القدس ومن يسيطر على
القدس يسيطر على ارض اسرائيل وفق تعبيرهم
صحيح هذا الكلام هو هو يعي تماما واقع
المعركه وطبيعه هذه المعركه ويرى كذلك
اهميه المسجد الاقصى المبارك ليس في
وتوحيد اهل مدينه القدس او حتى الشعب
الفلسطيني وحده بل انما كل الامه
الاسلاميه توحدت في شجب واستنكار ورفض
والغضب لكل ما يجري في المسجد الاقصى
المبارك من اعتداء من قبل الاحتلال لذلك
بالمختصر نقول ان الاحتلال يريد ان ينهي
الصراع يريد ان يستهدف رموز هذا الصراع
وجوهر هذا الصراع عبر استهداف المسجد
الاقصى المبارك ومدينه القدس وينهي فيها
اي
رفضا لسيادته او سيطرته على هذه المدينه
تصريح ايضا لافت السيد اسامه السعدي
وتصريح نتنياهو عندما قال ان القدس لن
تعود مقسمه ابدا
ولكنها ستظل مدينه مفتوحه
هل من شرح لهذه السياسه التي يراد لها ان
تكون في المدينه
انا مساء الخير لك وللضيوف وللمشاهدين
يعني
السياسه السياسه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
في المناطق التي تم احتلالها عام 67
الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه والقدس العربيه
درت التاج معروفه منذ ذلك الحين عندما تم
تشريع قانون اساس ان القدسيه العاصمه
الموحده الابديه لدوله اسرائيل للاسف
الشديد لا توجد هناك خلافات جذريه او
جوهريه ما بين الاحزاب الاسرائيليه او ما
بين الحكومات
المتعاقبه اذا كانت حكومات برئاسه بنيامين
نتنياهو في اخر 13 عام او حكومات حزب
العمل سابقا او حتى الحكومه السابقه ما
كانت تسمى حك التغيير برئاسه نفتالي بنت
ويائه لبيد حيث شهدنا وانت تذكر
والمشاهدين يذكرون انه
الاقتحامات والاعداد المستوطنين الذين
اقتحموا المسجد الاقصى المبارك في عهد
حكومه التغيير كان كانت اعداد غير مسبوقه
ويعني تضاعفت بشكل كبير ابان هذه الحكومه
ولذلك يعني من ناحيه وجهه النظر
المؤسسه الحاكمه
وجهه النظر الصهيونيه بالنسبه للقدس القدس
في نظرهم هي يعني هي عاصمه ابديه موحده
ويجب عدم تقسيم
هذه المدينه مع طبعا الدعاءات الفارغه
والشعارات الفضفاضه الفارغه من مضمونها
كما قلت انه بنيامين نتنياهو وكل
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين يقولون انهم
يريدون ابقائها مفتوحه وانها يعني يحترمون
حريه الاديان لا بل يعني جاء بنجفير هذا
الاحمق الذي يكشف الوجه الحقيقي لهذا
الاحتلال البشع الذي يقول نعم نريد حريه
عباده ايضا للجميع بما في ذلك اليهود
اليهود لا توجد لهم حريه عباده في المسجد
الاقصى المبارك اليهود لا يسمح لهم باداء
الشعائر الدينيه ولذلك نحن نرى انه يحاول
هو اعضاء حزبه واعضاء حتى كنيست من حزب
لكود الحاكم في الاسبوع الماضي في مسيره
الاعلام عندما يعني اقتحموا المسجد الاقصى
المبارك
ويعني انشدوا نشيد
القومي الاسرائيلي من داخل
ساحات الحرم ولذلك انا اقول انه في
النهايه
المشروع الصهيوني بما يتعلق بالقدس
العربيه هو عمليا تهويد هذه المدينه
المقدسه
محاوله تفريغها من سكانها الفلسطينيين
ولذلك يعني جاءت كل السياسات من سحب
الهويات سحب الاقامات جدار الفصل العنصري
الذي اخرج اكثر من 150 الف من مخيم شعفاط
ويعني مخيم قلنديا وكفر عقب وسميراميس
خارج
حدود حدود ما يسمى بلديه الاحتلال طبعا
سيد السعدي الاردن لا ينظر بارتياح لكل
هذه المسائل دكتور محمد الحناقه
الاردن الذي له الوصايه على المسجد الاقصى
والاماكن المقدسه في رغم انه اعرب اكثر من
مره عن استياء وادانته ولكن ذلك لم يغير
شيء من السياسه الاسرائيليه
كيف ينظر الى الى هذه الزاويه
مساء الخير لك وللاخوين الكريمين يا سيدي
المؤلم ان البرنامج الصهيوني لتهويد القدس
واضح المعالم ولا يترددون في الاعلان عنه
واخر اجتماع للحكومه الصهيونيه كانها تقول
بعد قمه جده وردا على البيان الذي صدر ان
ما فوق الارض لنا اي الاقصى ومساحته وما
تحت الارض لنا اشاره الى البحث عن هيكلهم
المزعوم فالبرنامج الصهيوني وانت قلت ان
الاردن غير مرتاح الحقيقه الاردن منقلق
جدا من هذا التطور وخاصه بعد رصد الملايين
لاستمرار الحفريات التي تهدد سلامه المسجد
الاقصى والاردن الحقيقه لا يتوانى عن
استثمار علاقاته الدبلوماسيه والسياسيه
سواء العربيه الاسلاميه والدوليه للضغط في
ات ايقاف هذا البرنامج الخطير والمعلن
والمتطرف وانا اظن ان اسرائيل الان ستنتقل
الى لم تجد من يردحها وتحيا للمقدسيين
المرابطين المدافعين عن القدس وعن المسجد
الاقصى ومن يازرهم الفلسطينيين الداخل لن
تتوانى في تطوير التقسيم الزماني والمكان
الى مرحله متقدمه ومن ثم محاوله التضييق
على سكان القدس وتقليص عددهم ومحاصرتهم
بالمستوطنات والبور الاسطانيه وتعقيد مهمه
الناس في الوصول الى الاقصى لذلك العبادات
والدفاع عنه ومن ثم المتطرفين يعني
يتوغلوا اكثر والمرحله الاخيره لا سمح
الله هو هدم المسجد الاقصى وبناء الهيكلات
هذا ليس خيالا علميا ولكن هذا هو البرنامج
الصهيوني فالاردن يعني يحاول بالرغم من
انه لديه بعض الادوات للضغط ولكن للاسف
هذه الادوات غير كافيه لايقاف المشروع
الصهيوني بسبب اولا وجود انقسام فلسطيني
انقسام عربي للاسف دعم واسناد امريكي
واوروبي الى حد ما وايضا الخنجر التطبيع
العربي الذي اتى لي يعني يذبح القضيه
الفلسطينيه بدون مقابل
فالمعاناه الفلسطينيه الحقيقه هي معاناه
الشعب الاردني اليوميه والاردن احيانا
بشكل علني واحلامنا بشكل غير معلن يدافع
بكل ما اوتي وما يستثمر كل الادوات
المتاحه لايقاف هذا البرنامج الخطير
لتهويد القدس
دكتور حليقه اشرت الى الى موضوع الحفريات
وفعلا من اخطر وابرز مظاهر التهويد
الحفريات والانفاق التي تستهدف المسجد
الاقصى ومحيطه كلها محاولات يائسه من
الاحتلال وخلال عشرات السنين لمحاوله
اثبات ما لم يفلحوا في اثباته من وجود
هيكل سلماء سليمان
والحق المزعوم لليهود في الاقصى ومحيطه
انطلقت اولى الحفريات في المسجد الاقصى
ومحيطه بعد اشهر من احتلال القدس عام 67
من القرن الماضي الحفر المنظم بدا عام 69
وناهز عدد الحفريات والانفاق حتى يومنا
هذا 64 داخل وخارج اسوار البلده القديمه
وفي محيط المسجد الاقصى واسفله وفقا
لمصادر الاوقاف الفلسطينيه ففي الجهه
الغربيه من المسجد الاقصى ناهز عدد
الحفريات والانفاق 28 نفقه وفي الجهه
الجنوبيه نهزت تلك الحفريات والانفاق 17
نفقا بينما ما يعرف من حفريات من الجهه
الشماليه بلغ خمسا اكبر هذه الانفاق النفق
الخاص بالحائط الغربي استمر حفره 26 عاما
وافتتح عام
1996 وادى لاندلاع ما عرف في حينه
بانتفاضه النفق ويمتد النفق بطول 450 مترا
تقريبا من اسفل المحكمه الشرعيه بمحاذاه
الجدار الغربي للمسجد الاقصى من الجنوب
الى الشمال مرورا بخمسه من ابواب الاقصى
ويجاور هذا النفق ويتصل به كل من نفق
سلسله الاجيال ونفقي حمام العين ومن
الانفاق البارزه في الجهه الغربيه نفق
الحي اليهودي والقاعه الكبرى اضافه الى
حفريات ساحه البراق
هذا اضافه الى حفريات باب الخليل وقلعه
القدس بعمق خمسه عشر مترا ومن الحفريات
البارزه حفريات قناه الحائط الغربي
وحفريات الزاويه الجنوبيه الغربيه وحفريات
القصور الامويه والمصلى المرواني وفي جنوب
المسجد وخارج الاسوار وتحديدا في مدينه
داوود تبرز حفريات الباب الثلاثي وقصر
داوود وعين سلوان ومن ابرز هذه الانفاق
واطولها نفق سلوان الممتد لاكثر من 600
متر في الجهه الجنوبيه ايضا وبعد كل هذا
التوكيب والحفريات والانفاق شكك اسرائيل
فنكشتاين كبير علماء الاثار في اسرائيل في
وجود اي صله لليهود بمدينه القدس واكد
لصحيفه جورج انه لا يوجد اي شاهد اثري يدل
على ان هيكل سليمان كان موجودا بالفعل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه سيد ناصر الهدمي خصصت
مبالغ كبيره
لمزيد جلب اليهود للعيش والاستقرار في
القدس وجعلها مدينه جاذبه لهؤلاء ولكن
الملفت للانتباه انه في استطلاع راي
للقناه الثاني عشر الاسرائيليه
62% من الاسرائيليين يرفضون العيش في
القدس
والمركز
الاحصاء دائره الاحصاء المركزيه
الاسرائيليه تقول انه منذ 2018
الف جاءوا للعيش في القدس ومع ذلك 30%
منهم غادروا لماذا لم تشكل بعد القدس نقطه
جذب حقيقيه
لاسرائيل حتى
تتمكن من فرض العنصر اليهودي فيها بشكل
كبير
نعم مدينه القدس لمن لا يعلم هي المدينه
الافقر من مدن دوله الاحتلال ونعم هي
مدينه طارده بحيث ان ميزان
الهجره اليها ومنها هو في السالب بمعنى ان
عدد من يهاجرون منها اكثر من عدد من
يهاجرون اليها او من يستوطنون فيها لذلك
نعم هي تعيش ظروف صعبه الحياه فيها ليست
سهله ليس فقط على الفلسطينيين هي المدينه
الاغلى هي المدينه الافقر هي المدينه
الاكبر صحيح اذا ما استثنينا ديمونا فلذلك
نقول ان مدينه القدس بالنسبه للاحتلال هي
مدينه طارده الان الاحتلال كما قلت يرى ان
لا سياده له ولا معنى لوجوده على ارض
فلسطين دون السيطره الكامله على مدينه
القدس بكل اجزائها لذلك هو دائما يسعى
لجلب
من المستوطنين ليعيشوا فيها وايضا يؤرقه
كذلك الميزان الديموغرافي هذا الميزان
الذي منذ عام
1967 وهو يشكل خطوره حتى ان رئيسه وزراء
الاحتلال في بدايه السبعينات اللي هي
جولداماير قالت يعني سالت عن نسبه العرب
في المدينه
بشقيها الشرق والغربي فكان الرد انه في
حينها انهم يوازون 23% من سكان المدينه
و77 البقيه مستوطنون يهود فكانت تقول انا
استطيع ان اتعايش مع هذا الامر
بعد ذلك حينما وضعت الخطه الهيكليه لمدينه
القدس التي انتهت بعام 2020 هذه الخطه
كانت تامل ان تستطيع حكومه الاحتلال ان
تصبح نسبه المقدسيين في المدينه لا تتجاوز
سته عشر بالمئه واذا بها اليوم تصل كما
ذكر تقريركم وتقارير اخرى نعم بين 39 الى
40% من سكان المدينه بشقيها هم فلسطينيون
رغم كل سياسات الافقار التهجير المطارده
سحب الهويات
الاعتقالات كل ما يواجه المقدسي من صعوبه
حياه وكل الاغراءات التي تصرف من قبل
سلطات الاحتلال لجلب مزيد من المستوطنين
رغم كل ذلك الا ان نسبه المقدسيين في
المدينه تزداد هذا امر يؤرق الاحتلال وهذا
يدفع نعم لوضع ميزانيات من اجل تغيير
الواقع الديموغرا طبعا اضافه الى خطط اخرى
ربما ليس المجال لذكرها لتعديل الميزان
الديموغرافي تزايد الاهتمام من قبل هذه
الحكومه سيد اسامه السعدي بالقدس وكل
التصريحات التي تطلق الان هل هو توجه
بالاساس من نتنياهو
لمسيره الصهيونيه الدينيه وبالتالي محاوله
طمس ما يلاحقه من قضايا وبالتالي هو
انتهازيه واضحه بالمزايده مع هذا التيار
لفرض وقائع جديده في القدس
لا اعتقد لانه كما قلت يعني في اجابه
السابقه انه لا توجد هناك فوارق جوهريه
بين نتنياهو وبين
بن جفير او حتى من ناحيه نفتالي بنت او
يعني بني جانس
ومع ذلك نقول دائما هذه الحكومه هي الاكثر
تطرفا في تاريخ اسرائيل اذا بهذا المعنى
هي فعلا اكثر تطرفا ممن سبقها
هذا صحيح لانه الان بنك فير وسبوطرش وطبعا
بدعم من نتنياهو لاسباب الخاصه اللي
تحدثنا عنها كثيرا وخاصه قضيه
المحاكمات ولواحل الاتهام ضد وفاه ابن
يمينه نتنياهو اضعف كرئيس حكومه من من
بنيامين نتنياهو قبل عشر سنوات او في
الدورات السابقه والان يعني بنغفير
وسبتريتش وحتى اعضاء كنيست ووزراء من حزبه
مثل يعني يعني يشعرون بانه بنيامين
نتنياهو ضعيف وبالتالي هم يبتزون منه
مواقف اذا كان ذلك مثلا في اقامه ما يسمى
الميليشيات الخاصه الحرس الوطني ما يسمى
الحرس الوطني وهو ميليشيات خاصه لبن فير
عندما هدد بنكير بانه لن يصوت مع الحكومه
وافق على اقامه هذه الميليشيات الخاصه في
الاسبوع الماضي عندما تم تصويت على
ميزانيه الدوله راينا انه يعني
ابتزوا في الساعات الاخيره مبلغ 250 مليون
شيكل اضافيه من الميزانيه اضافه الى تسع
ملياردات للميزانيه الشرطه ولذلك عندما
نرى انه يعني كل فتره وفتره يقتحم المسجد
الاقصى المبارك اعضاء كنيست من حزبه وزراء
من حزبه اعضاء كنيست من الليكود يقتحمون
المسجد الاقصى بالرغم من انه مثلا كل
الاحزاب
المتدينه الاخرى ما يسمى الحريدين
اصدروا بيانات وموشي جافني رئيس لجنه
الماليه ارسل برساله الى بنيامين نتنياهو
بان يمنع
الوزراء واعضاء الكنيست من اقتحام المسجد
الاقصى المبارك لانه من ناحيه دينيه
باعتقادهم انه خطا كبير وهذا حرام ما
تحاول هذه الحكومه الان هو استمرار
للسياسات السابقه المتعاقبه
بتهويد المدينه وبتقسيم المسجد الاقصى
زمانا ومكانا الكميات
المستوطنين الذين يقتحمون المسجد الاقصى
المبارك يوميا هي في تصاعد وفي استمرار
وتزايد مستمر ولكن في نهايه المطاف اعتقد
انه بالرغم من انه هناك يعني مرور 56 عام
من احتلال القدس ومحاولات مسيرات الاعلام
وكل المحاولات التي تقوم بها الحكومات
المتعاقبه الا انه لا تزال القدس المدينه
العربيه الفلسطينيه الاسلاميه المسيحيه
بالمسجد الاقصى وبكنيسه القيامه عندما
اشرت قبل قليل الدكتور حلايقه لموضوع
الحفريات والانفاق واستعرضنا في التقرير
هذه الرهيبه الحقيقه في القدس ومع ذلك كل
الجهود هذه الحفريات بدات في
1968 تكرست بشكل واضح منذ 69 مع ذلك لم
يعثروا على شيء
ذي قيمه يعني حتى المؤرخون الجدد كما
يسمون في اسرائيل او كبير المؤرخين وعلماء
الاثار يقولون لا لم نعثر على شيء فعلن
يؤكد هذا الترابط العضوي والتاريخي
والديني بشكل لا لبس فيه هل هذا يمكن
استغلاله عربيا على الاقل في مخططات
التصدي لهذه السياسات
نعم هو حتى اشرتم الى كلام فرانكشتاين
ومؤخرا قبل فتره ضعيف هيرتسوكو وهو من
كبار علماء الاثار والتاريخ في الكيان
الصهيوني اكد هذه الحقيقه وقال خمسين او
ستين سنه من الحفريات لم نعثر على شيء ولا
يوجد اثار لما يسمى بالهيكل ولكن يا اخي
هو كل الكيان الصهيوني كذبه كبرى كل كذبه
كبرى
الزي الشعبي الفلسطيني تلبسه المضيفات
الصهيونيات على طيران العال وكانه زي
صهيوني الاكلات الشعبيه الفلسطينيه
التقليديه والفول والحمص والفلافل اصبحت
اكلات شعبيه صهيونيه فهذا الكذب الصهيوني
هذا لا يتوقف عند حد هو ليس المهم انه
قناعتهم بوجود هيكل او عدم وجود هذا
البرنامج مستمر كما يتفضل الاخوين الذي
يسيطر على القدس على الاقصى يسيطر على
القدس والذي يسيطر على قطف فلسطين
بناء المملكه اليهوديه لا يوجد هيكل ولن
يجدوا هيكل ولكن هذه الحفريات وانا اعلم
من متخصصين ان الكيان الصهيوني قد يحاول
اجراء تفجيرات مصطنعه على شكل هزات ارضيه
مصنعه وقد اجريت تجارب بهذا الشان في
صحراء النقب لقياس مدى تاثيرها لا سمح
الله قد يلجا لحتى يبدو الامر انه نتيجه
عامل طبيعي على هذا الكذب الصهيوني
الادعاء الصهيوني للاسف لا يجد ما يردعه
لذلك كما تفضلت اليوم يعني لابد ان ينتبه
العالم الاسلامي هذا وقف الاسلامي هذا
المسجد الاقصى والقدس وايضا الفاتيكان
المقدسات المسيحيه موجوده وانا الان في
مشروع قانون عدم تفجير المسيح في الكنيست
لازم الجهد العربي الحقيقه الاعلامي
والسياسي ان يستثمر هذه النقطه ويستشهد
باقوال وكلام العلماء الموثق ان هذه كذبه
كبيره
الهدف هو لا سمح الله هدم المسجد الاقصى
هذا بدها جهد دبلوماسي بدها جهد اعلامي
ايضا من قبل الاخوه الفلسطينيين والجامعه
العربيه منظمه المؤتمر الاسلامي كل الجهات
المعنيه لانه اظن ان الموضوع وصل الى نقطه
خطره وحرجه لا يجوز الاستمرار في السكوت
عليها هذا يقودنا للحديث عن سبل التصدي
الحقيقيه اشرت الى منظمه التعاون الاسلامي
سيد ناصر الهدمي اجتماع الاخير في جده
تحدث عن اجتماع الحكومه الاسرائيليه
ادانوا ادان اقتحامات المستوطنين بكثير
دعا مجلس الامن الى ضروره التحرك والتاكيد
على ان القدس هي ارض محتله بالقانون
الدولي وبقراره مجلس الامن كيف يمكن لهذا
المجهود ان يتواصل وان يعطي نتيجه في
النهايه
يعني ربما ربما انا لست الشخصيه
الدبلوماسيه المحببه في هذا الموضوع ولكن
كوني اعيش في مدينه القدس وارى كل ما
تعانيه ويعانيه اهلها اقول ان يعني هناك
مئات وربما الالاف من قرارات الامم
المتحده القرارات الدوليه التي
حكمت وتحدثت عن القضيه الفلسطينيه وتحدثت
لصالح الشعب الفلسطيني واهمها قرار الامم
المتحده الذي اعتبر المسجد الاقصى واعتبر
حائط البراق ربما حتى قبلها عصبه الامم
المتحده تحدثت عن ان هذه املاك اسلاميه
خالصه وان لا يجوز لليهود ان يقربوا منها
او ان يصلوا حتى بجانب حائط البراق قرارات
كثيره صدرت منذ قيام دوله الاحتلال
المشكله والمعضله التي واجهها الشعب
الفلسطيني هو انه لم يتنفذ من هذه
القرارات اي شيء ليس هذا فحس بل هناك ايضا
تقصير من الجهه الرسميه الفلسطينيه
القياده الرسميه الفلسطينيه التي لم تسعى
لان يتم تطبيق وتنفيذ القرارات التي صدرت
لصالح الشعب الفلسطيني حتى يتم تجنيم
الاحتلال ووقف عند حده نحن كشعب فلسطيني
انا بقولها بكل وضوح لا نعول كثيرا على
المستوى الرسمي ولا على القرارات الدوليه
بقدر ما نعول بالدرجه الاولى على الشعوب
العربيه على ثبات الشعب الفلسطيني على
وحده الشعب الفلسطيني هذه كلها هي الذخر
وهذه كلها الظهر المحمي للشعب الفلسطيني
اما تقول لقرارات العديد من القرارات لم
تتحرك بينما قضيه روسيا واوكرانيا تحركت
الجيوش وتحرك الدعم العسكري لدعم اوكرانيا
واعتبر الدوله يعني تعيش اضطهاد المحتل
المجرم وتعيش تحت نير الاحتلال وقذائف
الاحتلال بينما الشعب الفلسطيني الذي واجه
كل اجرام الاحتلال منذ 75 عاما حتى يومنا
هذا واجه نكران الاحتلال للقرارات الدوليه
قرار تقسيم فلسطين الذي هو اعتراف بقيام
دوله الاحتلال كلها لم يعترف بها حتى
الاحتلال ولم ينفذها مع كل رفضنا لاي جهه
تقرر تقسيمه فلسطين او اعطاء حق لهذه
الدوله
بارض فلسطين او بذره تراب منها وربما
اللافت ايضا انه حتى الخارجيه الفلسطينيه
اشارت الى ان الان بعد كل هذا الذي يجري
مجرد السكوت على هذه الجرائم يعتبر جريمه
ومشاركه في الجريمه اللافت في المساله سيد
اسامه السعدي انه حتى الخارجيه الامريكيه
هذه المره
موقفها نوعا ما اقوى من السابق عندما
اعتبرت بان اعربت عن انزعاجها الشديد هكذا
بين بين قوسين لاجتماع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في مكان كان يفترض ابعاد
الاماكن المقدسه عن هذه المزايدات
السياسيه واعربت ايضا عن موقف يتعلق
بالاستيطان في اماكن
حتى بالقانون الاسرائيلي كان يفترض الا
تكون مستوطنات هل يمكن البناء على مثل هذا
الموقف الامريكي لي التقدم بشكل افضل في
الفتره المقبله
يعني صحيح انه الموقف الامريكي الان يعني
مختلف عن الموقف الذي كان في عهد الرئيس
ترامب
ابان ترامب كان هناك الاعلان عن القدس
والاعتراف بالقدس كعاصمه لاسرائيل وايضا
الاعتراف بسياده اسرائيل على هضبه الجولان
السوريه المحتله وايضا كان هناك تغيير في
موقفهم بخصوص بكل ما يتعلق بالاستيطان وان
الاستيطان بكل
اشكاله ومرفوض وهو عمليا يعتبر جريمه حرب
الان نرى يعني نغمه اخرى من الاداره
الامريكيه كما قلت في موضوع
الاجتماع الاخير للحكومه الاحتلال تحت
في انفاق
التي تحفر تحت المسجد الاقصى المبارك
وايضا بخصوص
واقتحام بنكير للمسجد الاقصى المبارك ولكن
هذه الحكومه ماضيه في مشاريعها
الاستيطانيه هناك على ارض الواقع الان يتم
بناء الاف الوحدات الاستيطانيه في المناطق
المحتله في الضفه الغربيه المحتله وفي
القدس المحتله هناك هدم بالجمله في
المدينه المقدسه بكل احيائها بنك فير
وشرطته الاحتلاليه وبلديه الاحتلال يقومون
بتنفيذ اوامر الهدم التي كانت في السنوات
السابقه هناك
اقتراحات قوانين وقوانين مررت
لتجريم الحركه الاسيره وحتى ابعاد
الاسرى المقدسيين لذلك هناك فعلا هجمه حتى
على التعليم
في المدينه المقدسه وراينا ذلك اليوم
عندما يح يعني فرض منهاج التعليم
الاسرائيلي على المدارس في القدس العربيه
المحتله ويحاولون حتى تغيير كتب الدراسه
والمنهاج التعليم
الفلسطيني بمنهاج تعليمي اسرائيلي ولذلك
الهجمه كبيره ولا يكفي بيانات الاستنكار
نحن نتوقع وشعبنا الفلسطيني واهلنا
المقدسيين
الصابرين الصامدين الذين طوال 56 عام
يناضلون ويعني صامدون في وجه هذا الاحتلال
البشع وانتصروا عليه في عده محطات في
معركه البوابات الالكترونيه وفي معركه باب
العمود ومصممون على الصلاه في المسجد
الاقصى المبارك الذي هو
ب144 دونم كل هذه المساحه هي حق خالص
للمسلمين ولكن يجب ان يكون هناك دعم عربي
اسلامي دولي
اهلنا في القدس خاصه وشعبنا الفلسطين عامه
واعتقد جمله اخيره اخي محمد انه يجب
استغلال الان هذه الحكومه الفاشيه في نظر
المجتمع الدولي وحتى في نظر الاداره
الامريكيه حتى يكون هناك ضغط دولي على هذه
الحكومه لتغيير سياساتها اتجاه شعبنا
الفلسطيني بشكل عام واتجاه القضيه قضيه
اهلنا المقدسيين والمسجد الاقصى المبارك
والاماكن المقدسه خاصه هذا الدعم العربي
الذي تشير اليه اشار اليه ايضا قبل قليل
الدكتور محمد حلايقه لكن على الاقل ما
لدينا الان على الاقل في انتظار
خطوات سياسيه افضل وارقى لدينا لجنه القدس
التي يراسها العهد المغربي محمد السادس
والعلاقات الاردنيه الاسرائيليه قائمه على
اتفاقات مكتوبه على ان المملكه الاردنيه
الهاشميه
لها الوصايه على الاماكن المقدسه ومع ذلك
لا نرى لجنه القدس تتحرك ولا نرى هذه
الاتفاقات الاردنيه الاسرائيليه تفعل ما
العمل
سيدي الكريم اخ محمد صحيح اولا يعني مؤلم
ان الدوله التي تراس لجنه القدس لم نسمع
لها صوتا ولم تقم باي دور فاعل وانا اقول
لك ان ربما هناك عتب اردني في هذا الموضوع
ولكن حفاظا على العلاقات الاخويه بين
المملكتين لا يعلن عن هذا الموضوع الامر
الثاني موضوع الوصايه الهاشميه اذكر ان
هذه الوثيقه وقعت بين الاردن والسلطه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ولم توقع بين الاردن
وسلطه الاحتلال ورد نص في اتفاقيه السلام
بين الاردن والكيان الصهيوني ولكن بتحليل
مفرداته القانونيه الحقيقي
لكن هذا النص فيه ضعف قانوني لانه ينص على
استمرار الدور الهاشمي بعد استكمال
المفاوضات بين الجانب الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي وعوده القدس الشرقيه الى
اهلها لدينا معضله واصلا حتى لو كان هناك
اتفاقيات مكتوبه من متى هم يحافظون على
المواثيق والعهود يا سيدي الكريم لا
يحافظون على العهود ولا مواثيق وانظر الى
ما جرى في اتفاق اوسلو والاتفاق والموقع
عليه في اتفاق اوسلو كل نسف ومؤخرا احد
اعضاء التيار ما يسمى باليسار الاسرائيلي
قال مشكلتي فلسطينيه انهم صدقونا
فاذا الا يركن الى موضوع المواثيق لكن
الاردن مستمر بكل الضغوط الدبلوماسيه
واغلقهم مؤخرا موضوع الحفريات والانفاق
وهو يقوم بجهد جهد معلن وجهد غير معلن لكن
اسمح لي انا ان هذا الموقف ان اوجه هذا
النداء الى سمول امير محمد بن سلمان رئيس
القمه العربيه
وناشده كمواطن عربي ومسلم
ان لا يخضع لكل الضغوطات لاي شكل من اشكال
التطوير مع الكيان الصهيوني هذا موقف مؤثر
سيحسب له في التاريخ وان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه براستها للقمه وتاثيرها السياسي
والاقتصادي وموقعها والحرمين الشريفين
بعلاقاتهم مع الاطراف تستطيع الحقيقه ان
تؤثر وتسند موقف الاردن وكل الاطراف
الحريصه على فلسطين وقضيه فلسطين والقدس
في انتظار
كهذا سيد ناصر الهدمي الدول العربيه التي
طبعت اذا اذا صدقنا اسرائيل في السابق كما
قال المشكله انهم صدقونا كيف لنا ان نقع
في نفس الفخ مره اخرى ونصدقهم مره اخرى
هنا نسال الدول التي طبعت اخيرا سواء
الخليجيه او المغرب او السودان او غيره هل
يمكن لها ان تتحرك بشكل يشكل ضغط حقيقي
على اسرائيل في موضوع القدس وفي موضوع
الاستيطان وفي غيرها من القضايا على الاقل
لفرمله هذا التوجه الابراهيمي كما يسمى
سلام الابراهيمي حتى
يشكل نقطه ضغط ربما تؤتي نتيجه
المستوى الرسمي العربي سواء الذي طبع مع
الاحتلال او الذي لم يطبع اذا ملك الاراده
واراد ان يواجه الاحتلال بقوه فهو يستطيع
نعم يستطيع نحن نعي كمان وهذا هذا مصدر
يعني حزننا
وعتبنا على هذا المستوى العربي نحن نعي
تماما ان هناك ضغوطات هناك ظروف معينه
يعيشها المستوى العربي الرسمي ولكن في
النهايه نحن نتحدث عن فلسطين نحن نتحدث عن
القدس نحن نتحدث عن كرامه الامه العربيه
والاسلاميه للاسف اننا ما نشاهده وما نرى
على ارض الواقع هو مجرد لقاءات قمم
مؤتمرات تعقد هنا وهناك والنتائج كلها
حديث النتائج كلها واستنكار وتعريف المعرف
والتاكيد على المؤكد ولا خطوات عمليه
باتجاه
ثمن جرائمه ليس فقط بحق الشعب الفلسطيني
بحق الشعوب العربيه والاسلاميه الا يعاني
الاردن من نقص في المياه لماذا لا تقف
حكومه الاردن دعك من موضوع
الوصايه الاردنيه التي يعني للاسف نحن نعي
تماما ان الاردن لا يريد ان يفقد هذه
الوصايه وليس من مصلحته ان يفقد هذه
الوصايه ولكن ما نعتب فيه هو لماذا يكون
هذا الضعف في مواجهه الاحتلال في وقف
الاحتلال عند حده لا يستطيع ان نفهم هذا
الضعف وهذا التخاذل كذلك كل مواقف الدول
العربيه سواء المطبعه او غير المطبعه
الاحتلال واضح جدا لديه تاريخ حافل من نقد
العقودات المواثيق الاتفاقيات كلها ينقضها
ولا ينفذ الا ما هو في مصلحته وبنفس الوقت
هو يجرم بحق الشعب الفلسطيني الذي هو اخ
وهو جزء من امه عربيه اسلاميه جمعاء لماذا
لا يكون هناك موقف عربي موحد
يلبي طموحات الشعوب وينفذ ما نسمع من كلام
في المؤتمرات في نهايه البرنامج السيد
اسامه السعدي
من خلال معرفتك بدواليب السياسه
الاسرائيليه الداخليه ما اكثر شيء يؤلم
ربما اسرائيل ويجعلها تتراجع عن هذه
السياسه لا نقول بالكامل ولكن على الاقل
تتراجع عن هذا الشطط في هذا التوجه
اولا ما يؤلمها انه يعني بالرغم من مرور
56 عام على احتلال المدينه المقدسه وعلى
توحيد المدينه كما تدعيه هي حتى الان يعني
ولا اي اسرائيل ولا اي وزير او مسؤول في
كل الحكومات المتعاقبه يستطيع ان يقول انه
فعلا وحدنا القدس والقدس موحده هناك على
ارض الواقع لا زال الاحتلال واضح لا زال
الفصل واضح بين القدس العربيه المحتله
وبين القدس
الغربيه ولذلك كل هذه مسيرات الاعلام وكل
هذه الاقتحامات
المتواصله والمستمره للمسجد الاقصى
المبارك فقط تاتي لتقول انه القدس ولكن
يعني اذا كان هناك يعني هذه مسيره الاعلام
بحاجه الى الاف افراد الشرطه حتى يحموا
هذه المسيره فهذا يقول ان القدس غير موحده
القدس محتله وفي نهايه المطاف كان هناك
يعني العديد من الاحتلالات
الاجنبيه لفلسطين والقدس وكل هذه
الاحتلالات
ذهبت وبقيت القدس عربيه فلسطينيه اسلاميه
ولكن اعتقد ان هناك دور مهم جدا
للاردن بصفته صاحب الوصايه على الاماكن
المقدسه وراينا انه عندما يكون الموقف
حازم اذا كان ذلك من الاردن او من الدول
العربيه الاخرى من مصر ومن من قطر ومن
الدول
المطبعه
اسرائيل تعمل الف حساب ولكن اسرائيل اخشى
ما تخشاه واكثر ما تخافوا هو هذه
الضغوطات الدوليه المحاكم
الدوليه وخاصه محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
[موسيقى]